NOW BACK TONIGHT
THERE' THE SEASON FOR
CALGARY JUST THROWS IT TO THE  .
HERE'S SHOT BY
BRENT BURNS, SET U
TONIGHT FOR CALGARY.
AS ADAM WORK
MARKSTROM, STARTING GOALTENDER'S
NUMBERS AND YON THEIR OWN
ZONE
IT'S TWO-ON-ONE.
AS I TO HELP OUTG  IT UP THE WIO
HANIFIN IN FRONT
LOOSE PUCK
THEY SCOREE
OF BACKLUND.
KARLSSON CAN
CALGARY FORECASTING TENACIOUSLYN
MOVES FROM LEFT TO RIGHT AND
MAKES A TERRIFIC STOP.
>> Randy: VLADAR BIG MAN
>> Randy: GREAT GNIZES, BOY, THS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP ON G I CO
GET OUT OF THE WAY OF THAT.
>> Bret: THAT'S A LOAD
BACK TO KARLSSON -
WHERE LOGAN COUTURE IS ALREADY
PARKED, , REBOUND, SCOOORES! NOE
NE PART THEY HAVE BEEN
A VERY FOR KYLINGTON
LOCE, OTHERWISE CALGARY'S DOWN
BY TWO
GUDBRANSON
TOMAS HERTL WITH AN EMPTY NET,
HE BURIES IT
SHOT FROM THE POINT, JUST IN